i've done a bunch of videos where i use
words like
pressure
and let me write these down pressure and
temperature
and
volume and i've done them in the
chemistry and the physics playlist and
then i especially in the physics
playlist but even in the chemistry
playlist i also use words like
kinetic energy
kinetic
i'll just write e for energy or i use
force
force and velocity
and you know a whole bunch of other
other types of uh i guess properties of
things for better or for worse and in
this video what i want to do is i want
to make a distinction because it becomes
important when we start
getting a little bit more precise
especially when we get more precise in
in thermodynamics or or i guess you know
the study of how how heat moves around
so these properties right here these are
properties of a system or we could call
them these these are macro states of a
system
macro states
macro
states
and these these could be macro states so
for example let me let me make it clear
when i call a system
if i have a
balloon
if i have some balloon like this
and it has a little tie there and you
know maybe has a string this has these
macro states associated with it there is
some pressure in that balloon
remember that's force per area
there is some temperature for that
balloon
temperature and there's some volume to
the balloon obviously but all of these
these help us relate what's going on on
that inside that balloon or what what
that balloon is doing in kind of an
everyday
reality before people even knew about
what an atom was or maybe they thought
that there might be such an atom but
they'd never proved it they were dealing
with these macro states they could
measure pressure they could measure
temperature they could measure volume
now we know that that pressure is due to
things like
you have a bunch of atoms
bumping around and let's say this is a
gas it's a balloon it's going to be a
gas
and we know that the pressure is
actually caused and i've done several i
think i did the same video in both the
chemistry and the physics playlist i did
them a year apart so you can see if my
my thinking has evolved at all
but we know that the pressure is really
due by you know just the the bumps of
these particles as they bump into the
walls of the side of the balloon and we
have so many particles that at any given
point of time some of them are bumping
into the wall of the balloon and that's
what's essentially keeping the balloon
pushed outward giving its pressure and
its volume we've talked about
temperature as essentially the average
kinetic energy of these of these blue
which is a function of these particles
which could be either the molecules of
gas or if it's a
if it's an ideal gas it could be just
the atoms of the gas maybe it's you know
atoms of helium or or
or or
or neon or something like that and all
of these things
these describe the microstates so for
example i could describe what's going on
with the balloon i could say hey you
know there are and i could just make up
some numbers i could you know
there the the pressure is
pressure is
you know let's say it's five newtons per
five newtons per
per meter squared or some number of
pascals the units aren't what important
the the in this video i really just want
to make the differentiation between
these two ways of describing what's
going on i could say the temperature
i could say the temperature is
300 kelvin i could say that the volume
the volume is i don't know maybe it's
one liter and i've described the system
but i've described it on a macro level
now i could get a lot more precise
especially now that i we know that
things like atoms and molecules exist
what i could do is i could essentially
label every one of these
molecules or let's say atoms in in the
gas or that's in contained in the
balloon and i could say at
exactly this moment in time you know i
could say time equals zero
molecule you know atom one has uh you
know it's its momentum is equal to
x and its position
its position in three dimensional
coordinates are
x y and z
right and then i could say atom number
two
it's momentum i'm just using rho for
momentum or p
it's equal to y and it's position
is a b c and i could go and give you
this i could i could list every atom for
in this molecule obviously we're dealing
with a huge number of atoms on the order
of 10 to the 20 something so it's a it's
a massive list i would have to give you
but i could literally give you the state
of every atom in in this balloon and
then if i did that i would be giving you
the microstates or i would give you a
specific microstate of the balloon at
this time now the if when a when a
system and i'm going to introduce a word
here because this word is important
especially as we go is in thermodynamic
equilibrium
so let me write that down equilibrium
and we learned about equilibrium from
the chemistry point of view and that
tells you you know uh the amount of
something going in the forward reaction
is equivalent to the amount going in the
reverse reaction and when we talk about
macro states thermodynamic equilibrium
essentially says that the macrostate is
defined that they're not changing if
this balloon is in equilibrium at at
time one its pressure will be its
pressure temperature and volume will be
these things and if we look at it a
second later its pressure temperature
and volume will also be these things
it's an equilibrium none of the macro
states have changed and actually i'll
talk about in a second in order for
these macro states to even be defined to
be well defined you have to be an
equilibrium i'll talk about that in a
second now
at second number at time equals zero you
might have this whole set of you know i
i went and i listed 10 to the 20th
something microstates of all of the
different atoms in this molecule but
then if i look at this this this these
gases a second later i'm going to have a
a completely different micro state right
because all of these guys are going to
have bumped into each other and and
given each other you know their momentum
and all sorts of crazy things could have
happened in a second here so i would
have a completely different microstate
so even though we're at thermite at
thermodynamic equilibrium and our macro
states stayed the same our microstates
are changing every you know gazillionth
of a second they're constantly changing
and that's why for the most part in
thermodynamics we we tend to deal with
these macro states
and actually most of thermodynamics or
at least most of what you'll learn in a
first year chemistry or physics course
it was it was devised or or it was
thought about well before people even
had a sense of what was going on at the
macro level and that's often a very
important thing to think about sometimes
when and we'll go into concepts like
entropy and internal energy and things
like that and then you're you know you
kind of rack your brain how does it
relate to atoms and sometimes and we
will relate them to atoms and molecules
but it's useful to think that the people
who first came up with these concepts
came up with them not really being sure
what was going on at the micro level
they were just measuring everything at
the macro level now i want to i want to
go back to this idea here of equilibrium
of equilibrium
because in order for these macro states
to be fined
the system has to be in equilibrium and
let me let me explain what that means
if i were to take a
let's say i were to take a cylinder
and we will be using this cylinder a lot
so it's good to get used to this
cylinder get a cylinder there and it's
got a piston in it
and that's just a it's kind of the roof
of the cylinder can move up and down
the roof of the this is the roof of the
cylinder the cylinder is bigger but
let's say this is a kind of a roof
of the cylinder and we can move this up
and down and essentially we'll just be
changing the volume of the cylinder
right i could have drawn it this way i
could have drawn it like a cylinder
you know my drawing skills are
i could have drawn it like this
and then i could draw on the piston like
this so there's some depth here that i'm
not showing we're just looking at the
cylinder front on
right and so at any point in time let's
say the gas is between the cylinder and
the floor of our container
you know we have a bunch of molecules of
gas here a huge number of molecules
and let's say the
we have a rock on the cylinder that cut
essentially let's say we're doing this
in space so everything above the piston
is a is a vacuum actually let me just
erase everything above
so let me just erase this stuff
just so you see it's we're we're doing
this in space and we're doing it in a
vacuum this so let me write that down so
all of this stuff up here
is a vacuum
which means essentially says there's
nothing there there's no pressure from
here there's no particles here just
empty space and in order to keep this we
know already we've studied it multiple
times that this gas is generating you
know things are bumping into
into this the wall of this the floor of
this piston all the time they're bumping
into everything
right we know that's continuously
happening so we need to apply some
pressure to offset the pressure being
generated the gas otherwise the piston
would just expand it would just move up
and the whole gas would expand so let's
just say we stick a big rock
we stick a big rock or a big weight
on top let me do it in a different color
we put a big weight
on top of this piston
where the with the the force create is
completely offsets the force uh being
applied by the gas and obviously this is
some force over some area right the area
of the piston
over some area so we could figure out
its pressure and that pressure will
completely offset the pressure of the
gas but the pressure of the gas just as
a reminder is going in every direction
the pressure on this plate is the same
as the pressure on that side or on that
side or on the bottom of of the of the
container that we're dealing with now
let's say that we were to just evaporate
this well let's say let's not say that
we evaporate the rock let's say that we
we just evaporate half of the rock
immediately right so all of a sudden our
our weight that's being pushed down or
the force that's being pushed down just
goes to half immediately
let me draw that
so i have maybe better off just
cut and pasting this right here
so if i copy and paste it
so now i'm going to evaporate half of
that
rock magically
let me take my eraser
tool and i just evaporate half of it
and now what's going to happen
well
this piston
is now applying half the force it can't
offset the pressure due to this gas so
this whole thing is going to be pushed
upwards but i did it so fast i did it so
fast you could try it i mean it's you
know this would be true of a lot of
things if you had a weight hanging from
a spring and you just remove half the
weight it wouldn't just go very you know
nice and smoothly to another state
what's going to happen is and let me see
if i can do this using their cut and
paste tool
it'll essentially right when i evaporate
half of it the gas is going to expand a
bunch and then this weight is going to
come back down it's going to spring and
go down so let me do it again it's going
to expand because that gas is going to
push up and then it's going to come back
down and then you know it's just going
to oscillate a little bit and then
eventually it'll come back to some
stable and maybe it'll go back it'll be
like right about there
and let me fill this in this this is
this shouldn't be white this should be
black let me put some walls on it
on the container
some walls in the container
so if we wait long enough eventually
we'll get to another equilibrium state
where this thing isn't the piston on top
isn't or the ceiling isn't moving
anymore and now the gases
has filled this container
now at this point in time we were in
equilibrium the pressure throughout the
gas was the same the temperature
throughout the gas was the same the
volume
was in a stable situation it wasn't
changing from second to second so
because of that our macro states were
well defined
macro
states
well defined
now
when we wait long enough this thing will
get to some stability where this thing
stops moving when this thing stops
moving our volume stops changing and
hopefully our pressure will start become
uniform throughout the container and our
temperature will become uniform it will
now be a higher volume a lower pressure
probably a lower temperature if we
assume that there's no other heat being
added to the system and then we'll be
well defined again
we'll be well defined again so we could
say what the pressure and the volume of
the temperature is going temperature is
going to be but what about right when i
removed this rock and this thing flew up
and it oscillated and for a while the
pressure at the top was lower than the
pressure down here maybe the temperature
at the top was lower than the
temperature down here the whole thing
was in a state of flux it was not an
equilibrium and at that point when we're
let me let me draw that really so you
know we were in that state where
everything was just crazy right when we
evaporated the rock
you know we have a little rock up here
everything is going up and down maybe
the pressure up here
was lower than the pressure
was than the lower than the pressure
down here the temperature was lower than
the temperature everything did not have
a chance to reach an equilibrium at this
date and this is important especially as
we go into talking about things like
reversible reactions and uh reversible
processes and and quasi static processes
at this point the reaction when we just
did this
none of these macro states were well
defined you couldn't tell me what the
volume of the system is because it's
changing for every second to second it's
or microseconds of microsecond it's
fluctuating you couldn't tell me what
the pressure of this system is because
it's changing every second you couldn't
tell me what the temperature is maybe
the temperature could be you know if i
did this as the temperature could be
something there it could be something
there all sorts of crazy things are
happening so when the system is in a
state of flux your macro states are not
well defined
and i really want to hit that point home
so let me just draw that in a diagram
let me draw that in a pv diagram and
we're going to use these fairly heavily
so on my y-axis i'm going to put
pressure in my x-axis i'm going to put
volume
so our initial state here when we had
the rock sitting on top of this ceiling
this movable ceiling or this piston
maybe we had some well-defined pressure
and volume so my y so this is pressure
and this is volume so this is where we
started off so it was well defined this
is state one let me label it right there
this is state one
now
when we evaporated half the rock we got
we eventually and we waited long enough
and this got to an equilibrium we got to
state two and our pressure volume and
our temperature was well defined and
i'll just put it on this pressure volume
so maybe this is state two
we got down here
and just as a side why you know i could
maybe put temperatures in extra
dimension but temperature is completely
determined by pressure and volume
especially if we're dealing with an
ideal gas remember and we did this in
multiple videos you know you have pv is
equal to
well we could eat well i'll write n
r t
these are these are constants the number
of moles isn't changing this is
the universal gas constant not changing
so if you know p and v you know t so
that's the only two things we have to
plot but i'll talk a lot more about that
in future videos but the important thing
to realize is i started off at this
state
where pressure and volume were well
defined i finished in this state
defined but how did i get there and
because this reaction i did all of a
sudden it happened super fast and it was
essentially thrown out of equilibrium
out
of equilibrium
uh equilibrium
i don't know how i got here this this
pressure and volume were not well
defined from going from that state to
this state pressure and volume and
temperature are only well defined if if
every if every
every intermediate step is still almost
in equilibrium and we'll talk a lot more
about that in the next video but i want
to really make this point home it would
be nice if we could draw some you know
path we could say oh you know as every
we moved from
some pressure and volume to some other
pressure in volume and we moved along a
well-defined path but we cannot say that
because when we went from there to there
our definitions just disappeared for
pressure and volume we cannot define
those those macro states
and these intermediate non-equilibrium
states now just as a little aside we
could have defined the microstates the
microstates never change at any given
snapshot in time i could have listed
every particle that's in this thing and
i could have given you its kinetic
energy i could have given you its
position i could have given you its
momentum and there's no reason why i
couldn't have done that so i could have
actually made a you know i could have
made a plot of one particular particle
and i could have said what it's kinetic
energy and it's over at a course of time
is it any given moment in time and this
is really important so microstates are
always well defined the microstates
what's exactly happening to the atom in
terms of its force and its velocity and
its and its momentum
while macro states are only defined are
only i should say well defined when the
system in this case is the balloon in
this case is this piston on top of the
cylinder this movable ceiling the
macrostates are only well defined when
the system is in equilibrium or where
you can essentially say when you say the
pressure is x the pressure is the same
throughout or the volume isn't changing
from moment to moment or the temperature
is the same thing throughout
anyway i'll leave you there and we'll
talk more about why i went through all
of this pain in the next video